Hello everyone, this
is Isaac Kurtz of the
Department of
Biomedical Science, Old
Westbury Campus, and
this will be another of
the lectures on the
supraspinal motor
systems, this one
concerning the cerebellum.
We have four session
objectives for our
lecture today. First off,
we need to understand
the general organization
of the cerebellum.
There's lobes of
the cerebellum, just
like the cerebral cortex.
What are they? where
are they, nuclei for
the cerebellum, input
pathways, output pathways
for the cerebellum,
and so on. Then we
need to understand
how those inputs and
outputs are linked to
different parts of the
brain, spinal cord,
brainstem, and cerebrum.
And then we need
to zoom on in and say
how is it that the
circuitry of cerebellum
is allowing it to do
its job? What does
that mean on that more
detailed circuit level
and lastly we need to
understand the regional
specialization of
the cerebellum just
like you have for the
cerebrum it's divided
into various regions
what are those functions
for these various
regions and what occurs
when we have deficits
cerebellum means
little brain in Latin.
And like the big brain,
the cerebral cortex,
it is a gray matter
sheet that has many
different folds so
that we can pack in as
much processing into a
confined space. But the
little is a bit of an
exaggeration because,
in fact, if you were
to unroll that sheet,
it has about 80% of
the surface area of
cerebral cortex and 80
percent of the neurons
in the brain so that
that's quite shocking
if you just looked at
it maybe they'd name
it otherwise if they
knew those facts at
the time regardless
it is a region of the
brain that is critical
for coordination and
damaging it will lead
to um significant issues
in coordination be
it your eyes be it
moving your body moving
your limbs or speaking
and so on but you do
not have a diminishment
of strength if one
was to have cerebellar
damage you can take
it out uh entirely
and you'd be just as
strong just be terribly
coordinated because
that's really what
its job is is a part
of the extrapyramidal
system so its
neurons are going to
be impacting the
upper motor neurons,
which themselves
directly influence the
lower motor neurons,
but it doesn't
influence the lower
motor neurons itself.
Now, there are many
different functions of
the cerebellum, as
one could imagine, for
a structure that is
so extensive being
80% of the surface
area of the cerebral
cortex but most of our
understanding is about
motor coordination
there's less understanding
about its role
in cognition and
emotional processing
the last thing I want to
mention here is a
interesting historical
fact is that we
developed some of
our modern
understanding of the
cerebellum due
to neurologists
examining World War
One vets, British,
and they suffered, a
number of them suffered
damage to the cerebellum
because of the
particular hat they
were wearing as opposed
to the Germans that
had a different hat
helmet and this some
of the key observations
that were made there
in terms of ataxia
stand with us to this
day as mentioned in
the slide before most
of our understanding
about the cerebellum
concerns its role in
motor coordination
whereas undoubtedly it
has a much broader
role it is ultimately
going to be getting
influences from parts of
the cerebral cortex
that are not related
in any obvious
way to motor
coordination like
prefrontal cortex
for example but
our understanding
of those capabilities
are limited
because people just
aren't doing the
studies there's
about But 10% of the
research on the
cerebellum is there
is to the cortex,
which is obviously
not matching the 80%
of its cortical surface
and 80% of the neurons
in the brain. So
if you went by neurons,
you went by surface
area, it doesn't
match how much time is
being spent on these
areas. I'm just pointing
to some recent research
that's trying to
bridge these gaps. These
are things that are
in development that
you have. activation
of the cerebellum
during a mental rotation
task or when the person
is trying to think
of different verbs
like run and jump and
so on so it is involved
in cognitive functions
we're going to be
pushing that off for
the rest of the talk
you slides really gonna
be going into some
more detail about the
anatomy of the
cerebellum and what what
comprises its organization
there are lobes and
regions of the cortical
sheet comparable
to what we have for
cerebral cortex here we
also have these
distinctive peduncles which
are going to be
fiber tract hearing
information to cerebellum
or away from cerebellum
internal nuclei this
is a very distinct
feature of the cerebellum
there's going be
nuclei that will be
its output from the
cerebellum and they're
inside the cerebellum
and then there are
associated external
nuclei these are nuclei
that are intimately
related to the
cerebellum they provide
inputs to the cerebellum
but they are not
cerebellum per se and
we'll go through each
of those in its turn
the folded gray matter
sheet of cerebellar
cortex is divided
into three lobes, two
of which we see from
this bandage, which
is superior. I'm a
bird flying above and
the googly eyes are
pointing straight ahead.
There is the anterior
lobe, which is
suitably in the front.
There is the posterior
lobe, posterior to
it. The two are
divided by the primary
fissure the posterior
lobe is going to continue
wrapping underneath
and then there's
gonna be a floccular
nodule lobe which is
hidden inside here
we'll see it soon enough
now there are different
regions of the
lobes and the centermost
region the midline
region is called vermis
like worm. I don't
see a worm here, but
the anatomist did.
And then there are the
hemispheres. You have
a hemisphere to the
left, you have a
hemisphere to the right
for both the anterior
posterior lobe
and the floccular
nodule lobe that
we'll get to soon.
Now you can divide that
hemisphere into the
lateral division and the
medial division. So
the lateral is the most
lateral and the medial
is what abuts the
vermis and continues
out about an inch or so
and that's also called
paravermal but we'll
call it medial hemisphere
here we have the
disembodied cerebellum
again this time from
the inferior view so it'd
be as if this person's
laying on their back
and were able to see
up their nose. Let's
get rid of that now.
And we have a great
view of the posterior
lobe because that's
really most everything
that we see from this
vantage. The posterior
lobe is wrapping
around on the backside
and the composes the
underneath of the
cerebellum. No, you
cannot see the anterior
lobe from this view,
but we are able to see
some of the phallocular
nodule lobe, which
is sticking out
right in front. I'm
highlighting it right
here. You can see this
little outcropping.
There's a little out
propping right there as
well and it looks kind
of like a bumpy tongue
so it's sandwiched
on the anterior side
between the anterior
lobe and the posterior
lobe which is
wrapping up underneath
it and making kind of
a floccular nodule
sandwich between those
two now you have
the midline region
continuing so you have
vermis on the anterior
lobe, vermis on the
posterior lobe, and
vermis on the inferior
portion of the
posterior lobe. You
also have the lateral
hemispheres and the
medial hemispheres so
these are just general
designations that
you have that span
the different lobes.
Here we have a mid
-sagittal view of the
cerebellum with the cerebrum
and brainstem intact.
I can draw a little
googly eye here for
references. The googly
eye is looking forward.
That is anterior. And
there are three lobes
that we're able to
see in this view and
not in the other views.
There is the anterior
lobe which is the most
anterior and superior
of the three and that
will be separated
from the posterior lobe
by the primary fissure
the posterior lobe is
going to continue on
the underside of the
cerebellum it is the
underside of the
cerebellum and sandwiched
between the two is the
floccular nodule lobe
and so this particular
division of the floccular
nodule lobe is called
the flocculus and
those outcroppings
that we saw from the
inferior view those
would be the flocculi so
there's one for the
left there's one for the
right it's a paired
structure and then the
verbal region of the
floccular nodule lobe
is the nodulus and
that lobe is separated
from the posterior
lobe by the posterior
lateral fissure and
so this view um really
does a nice job showing
the relative sizes
of these three lobes.
This one is by far
the smallest, the
floccular nodule lobe.
They'll be followed by
the anterior lobe, which
is nothing to be trifled
with, but is only
a half of what you
see in the superior
view, whereas the
posterior lobe is so much
more developed. It
takes up the rest of the
superior view and all
of the region underneath
it here we have a
cartoon cross-section
of the cerebellum and
the adjoining brain
stem that shows the
relative positions of
the deep cerebellar
nuclei and called deep
cerebellar nuclei
because they're deep
within in the folds
of the cerebellum
that's how you have
to cut on through it
because they're all
hidden away and there
are three groups on
each side most laterally
we have the dentate
nucleus which is
shown in red you can
see how large that is
it's supposed to look
like teeth so i'm told
we have the interposed
uh nuclei and so
that means that they're
in between the dentates
and then the most
medial nucleus which
is the fastigal and
there's names for these
interposed which you
don't need to you're
not going to be held
to globosa ebola form
and I should note that
we have the nodulus
at this level of the
section that's sticking
on out and that's as
you might remember
the vermal portion of
the floccular nodule
lobe and so you're
only able to see these
nuclei with a together
at a very specific
section because though
the dentate is quite
large these other nuclei
are relatively small
and would be hidden
within that white
matter that's what I'm
drawing around right
here this the white
matter which are axons
um for the cerebellum
information going in
and information going
out now i should mention
right now what is
the general function
of these these are the
output nuclei of the
cerebellum so you
have processing within
the cerebellar cortex
then we'll be sending
axons which
terminate onto
these deep
cerebellar nuclei.
And then these deep
cerebellar nuclei, DCN,
will be projecting axons
out back to the rest
of the nervous system.
So this is a gate
out of the cerebellar
cortex. It's an interesting
flip to the gate
to cerebral cortex,
which I trust that you
remember is a thalamus.
Now we have two different
examples of actual
brain tissue sectioned
in a way that
brings out the deep
cerebellar nuclei. The
image on the left is
from a frontal section
and so this highlights
the general geometry
of the cerebellum
quite nicely insofar as
the more medial region
is much more elevated
than the lateral
regions we can see that
this curves on down and
that's to accommodate
the temporal lobes
they're just kind
of sitting down on top
of the cerebellum now
returning to deep
cerebellar nuclei we can
see this massive dentate
gyrus I hope that
you can see these
paired structure for
the interposed nuclei
as well as the medial
festigal nuclei.
And again, I want to
point out how large
that dentate nucleus
is and that it's
situated most laterally.
The image on the
right is interesting.
It's all the white
matter has been scraped
away above it and
to the side and
around it. And so you
can really see that
these These are these
structures of this
crumpled nature, this
dentate nucleus, while
these other nuclei
are more compact,
interesting pebbles.
There are a number of
nuclei that are not of
the cerebellum, but
they have an intimate
relationship with the
cerebellum. And this
will include the red
nucleus, the pontine
nuclei, the vestibular
nuclei, and the inferior
olive. We're going to
be covering this in
more detail and in
several places, so we
don't have to cover
everything right now. We'll
get to this again and
again and again. But
I want you to remember
that you've seen the
red nucleus before
within the rostral
midbrain. And so that is
going to be receiving a
powerful output from
the cerebellum. I mean
powerful in the sense
of many different
fibers from the cerebellum
will be targeting
the red nucleus, and
that will be from the
contralateral side. We
have the pontine nuclei,
which we encountered
for a brainstem and
anatomy lecture. I was
saying, well, these
are going to be
providing inputs to the
cerebellum. And you might
remember that would be
the axons of the
pontine nuclei form the
middle cerebellar peduncle.
there's the vestibular
nucleus or found
within rostral medulla
and that's going to
be sending inputs to
cerebellum and they'll
be receiving outputs
from cerebellum as well
and then there is the
inferior olive found
in the upper half of
the medulla and that's
going to be relaying
inputs to the cerebellum
as well and so
there's a lot of information
here about like well
it's control this one's
consular this one's
epsilon we'll break
that up in some
subsequent slides I just
thought it would be a
good place to to
introduce that information
now and set that
machinery in your mind in
motion okay Okay, very
quickly, this is just
pointing to actual
sections, transverse
sections through the
brainstem, showing the
inferior olive within the
medulla, showing within
rostral medulla, the
vestibular nucleus,
showing within the pons,
pontine nuclei, and
showing within rostral
midbrain that enormous
red nucleus we have a
view of the cerebellum
which we have not
seen before and that
is looking at it directly
head-on so if the
person's head was intact
we'd be looking at
their eyes but instead
we We removed all of
them, sectioned the
cerebellum from the
brain, and the cerebellum
just kind of floating
in space. That's
what we're looking at
straight ahead. And this
is able to bring out a
number of important
features of the general
anatomy of the cerebellum.
We'll begin with
the peduncles, which
will be communicating
between the cerebellum
and everything else.
You have to have fiber
tracts, axons, that
are collected together,
sending information
to the cerebellum.
And then we'll leave
information from the
cerebellum. No Wi-Fi. so
we have the superior
cerebellar peduncle the
middle cerebellar
peduncle and then this
inferior cerebellar
peduncle in addition we
can now see the flocculus
sandwiched between
the drawing it right
here I'm assuming you
can see it on this
other side that would be
sandwiched between the
anterior lobe above it
and the posterior
lobe underneath it and
to the side of it okay
and so it's otherwise
it is pretty much
hidden this is the best
way we can see the
blockless and see that it
is this paired structure
the nodulus is the
mid-line portion of
the phallocular nodule
lobe. So it is actually
connected to the
phalloculus. It's kind
of hidden underneath
this peduncle. So it
will be connected to
the phalloculus and
that will be the vermal.
It's like the
vermis of the
phallocular nodule lobe.
Lastly, I want to mention
this large portion
on which is part of
the posterior lobe
and it is inferior and
most medial and we can
see how distinctive
its swellings are this
is the tonsil so the
tonsil is part of the
posterior lobe and
the tonsils comes up
again and again in
clinical scenarios because
these could be
displaced through the
foramen magnum if you
have enough pressure from
above with hydrocephalus
or if there's some
underdevelopment of
the cerebellum so
that it can't resist
the pressure from above.
This is called Chiari
formations and so you
can see why that would
be the case because
they're on the inferior
side and they're
the most medial portion
of that posterior
lobe the cerebellar
communicates with three
major portions of the
nervous system the
spinal cord the brainstem
and the cerebral
cortex that means it's
going to be receiving
information from all
of these and it's going
to be relaying
information to most of
these it's not going to
be directing directly
sending axons to
target the spinal cord
but it will be receiving
information from the
spinal cord likely
remember the dorsal and
ventral spinal cell
valetraxel from the
spinal cord, and
they'll be going to the
cerebellum because it
says spinal cerebellum.
And there's a
number of tracts
from the brainstem.
We talk about
those major
peduncles, but within
a peduncle, there's going
to be many different
tracts from various
structures, which
we'll touch on shortly.
And then for the
cerebral cortex, you
can see for all the
regions that are not
colored yellow. We know
in the monkey that it
is sending afferents
to the cerebellum,
so it's a wide amount
of territory and these
are regions that are
not sensory motor at
all necessarily like
the temporal lobe
that's a sensory motor.
So there's a lot of
information that's flowing
into the cerebellum.
Now an important
feature of the cerebellum
that separates,
excuse me, separates
it from the cerebral
cortex is that it's
involved in controlling
the ipsilateral body.
And the cerebral cortex
is involved in controlling
the contralateral
body. So that means
that it needs to
be some information
that crosses from right
to left and left to
right for these two
structures to communicate
with each other.
This is a listing of
all the afferents and
efferents within the
peduncles and what I'm
trying to do is to
impress the variety of
structures or types
of information that is
being relayed to the
cerebellum. So the afferents
are going to include
a vestibulocerebellum
or So for the face,
reticulocerebellar,
the libocerebellar,
again and again,
many detectocerebellar,
many different
types of information
flowing in.
A corticopontine
cerebellar is
enormous, so
all the stuff
ultimately from the
cerebral cortex.
And then there's going
to be outputs from
the cerebellum
targeting many different
areas. The thalamus,
red nucleus, tectum,
vestibular nuclei,
reticular formation,
on and on. You are
not expected to know
all of this. It's not
to give you, you know,
heart palpitations,
but to kind of
understand the breath.
What you need to know
is on the next slide.
I've done a major
simplification here for
the inferior, middle,
and superior peduncles,
but one that
captures most of the
complexity that we saw
in the previous slide,
which is that we can
start off the middle
period cerebellar
peduncle. There's no
simplification there
because these are all
afferent fibers.
They're traveling to the
cerebellum that originate
in the pons. Those
are the pontine nuclei.
They're doing it,
relaying that information,
and they receive
inputs from the cerebral
cortex. so that's
cortical pontine
cerebellar that is that
is definitely the case
the inferior peduncle
it's we're just going
to say that this
will be comparing all
of the aphrod tracks
it's not entirely true
but we will it's a
best place to to
make a simplification
whereas the superior
peduncle is the primary
output of the cerebellum
primary relay of
the cerebellum so when
talk about the superior
peduncle those will
be the efforts there
are three major
functional divisions of
the cerebellum and
these reflect different
degrees of motor
sophistication and
they reflect different
points in how
we have evolved to
be where we are now.
So the vestibulocerebellum
is going to be
processing information
about orientation. So
it'll be processing
signals from the vestibular
nuclei and that will
be targeting the
floccular nodule lobe.
So it's involved in head
-eye coordination
imbalance and this is
present in the earliest
vertebrate that we are
aware of so that's a
picture of a jawless
fish which would like
predate dinosaurs so
this has been around for
a long time so a spinal
cerebellum would be
those regions of the
cellum cerebellum
including the vermal or
vermis vermal and
paravermal regions so that
would be medial
hemisphere of the interior
and posterior lobe and
this will be receiving
inputs primarily from
the spinal cord and
this is important for
axial control and gait
and so on well developed
in a kitty cat and
then we have the
cerebrocerebellum which is
going to be processing
information from the
cerebral cortex so this
would be the lateral
hemispheres of the
two lobes and it will
be receiving input
ultimately from the vis-a
-vis the pontine nuclei
so that's how information
from the cerebral
cortex is transmitted
to the cerebellum is
through those pontine
nuclei so here we have
a fella jamming away
and that took a lot
of time and effort and
nascent ability to
achieve his level of
guitar mastery and so
that would be requiring
the cerebral cerebellum
the three functional
divisions of the
cerebellum reflect the
cortical particular
cortical territories the
particular portions of
the loaves but also the
cerebellar nuclei
which are the output of
the cerebellum the
vestibular cerebellum stands
alone in that it
does not require any
output nucleus it's the
simplest of the structures
and it does not have
its own dedicated
output nuclei it just
sends output from the
its cortical territory
while the others do
have output nuclei the
most prominent of these
is the dentate nucleus
which is situated
most laterally and is
associated with the
lateral hemisphere which
is the cerebro cerebellum
so you could see how
those those those
things go together a
large lateral nucleus
and this large elaborated
cerebrocerebellum.
All the remaining nuclei
and cortical territory
would fall within
the spinocerebellum.
This slide diagrams
the flow of information
between the cerebral
cortex and the
cerebellum. As you know,
the cerebral cortex
is involved in controlling
the contralateral
body while the
cerebellum is involved
in the control the
ipsilateral body. And
so for these two
structures to communicate
with each other needs
to be a decussation
of information. And
it goes as follows.
The cerebral cortex
would be sending its
fibers down to the
pontine nuclei. These are
corticopontine fibers.
These would be part of
the cru cerebri targeting
the pontine nuclei.
Those efferents from
the pontine nuclei are
crossing the midline,
forming the middle
cerebellar peduncle,
entering into the cerebellum,
and then the
cerebellum on that same
side would be sending
efferents out through
the superior cerebellar
peduncle to the
contralateral thalamus,
which will be communicating
with the ipsilateral
cerebral cortex so
thalamus sends its
outputs always going to be
targeting that ipsilateral
cerebral cortex
and so there's that
decussation of the superior
cerebral peduncle
that we see in the
midbrain it will be
targeting among other things
the contralateral
thalamus before the red
nucleus is going to be
tightly related to the
cerebellum receiving
inputs from the
contralateral cerebellum
so that a decussation that
is the superior cerebral
peduncle going left
to right it will be
targeting the contralateral
red nucleus red
nucleus will be
communicating to the
ipsilateral inferior olive and
And then this structure
will be communicating
with the contralateral
cerebellum. So it's
really hard to keep
it in words. So that's
why it's so much
better to draw out. And
you should note that
this communication from
the olive to the
contralateral cerebellum is
vis-a-vis the inferior
cerebellar peduncle.
We have the communication
of the vestibular
nucleus with the
cerebellum. this
will all remain on
one side there is no
decussation so the
vestibular nucleus of
one side will say the
right will be sending
its outputs to the
cerebellum through
the inferior cerebellar
peduncle remember
peduncle is the
primary input to the
cerebellum for everything
that is not pontine
okay so everything
else that's the input
to the cerebellum
all the other
appearances are carried
through the inferior
cerebellar or peduncle
and then there'll be
communication back to
that vestibular nucleus
on the same side vis
-a-vis this appears
cerebellar or peduncle
whereas the previous slides
showed how information
is relayed to the
cerebellum and from
the cerebellum. Here
we're going to get some
insight into the processing
within cerebellum.
So there is the deep
cerebellar nuclei
and the cerebral cortex.
And you remember, or
so I hope, that the
principal output of the
cerebellum is through
these deep cerebellar
nuclei with the exception
of the floccular
nodule lobe. Now
these deep cerebellar
nuclei are going to
be getting inputs from
three main sources of
information. One is
going to be from the
cerebellar cortex itself
and these are the
output cells are called
purkenji cells and
they will project to
the deep cerebellum
nuclei and they'll be
inhibiting it okay the
um other two inputs
would be the mossy fibers
and climbing fibers
so those are going to
be originating from
somewhere outside
the cerebellum the
climbing fibers are
exclusively through the
inferior olive so the
inferior the olivo
cerebellar tract will
be targeting the deep
cerebellar nucleus and
it will be excitatory
synaptic release will
be releasing glutamate
we also have the
mossy fibers which is
everything else
everything else that is
not from the olive
would be its axons are
the mossy fibers and
that will also be
excitatory inputs
glutamatergic inputs and
so we can see something
like a different
signal here where
there's going to be a
positive and a negative
and the difference
between those is the
cerebellar outputs.
So what is going on in
the cerebellar cortex
is the processing
of these, of some
different types of
signals, a measured signal
and then a highly
processed signal. And
so it's these measured
signals and then
ultimately this highly
processed signal from
the cortex that is
going to be compared.
The cerebellar cortex
has three layers to
it. There is the molecular
layer, the granule
cell layer, and the
Purkenji cell layer. The
granule cell layer
is going to be filled
with granule cells. There
are so many of these
granule cells, more
than all the other
cells of the nervous
system combined because
they're very, very
small and packed very,
very tightly together.
The Purkenji cell layer
is one layer thick
of Purkenji cells. So
that's the cell bodies
of them. And they are
providing the output
of the cerebellum. The
granule cells provide
input to the Purkenji
cells because the
Purkenji cell dendrites
are in the molecular
layer and the axons of
the granule cells are
in the molecular layer.
So that means that a
Purkenji cell is going
to be contacted by many,
many, many different
granule cells and
that is the data
compression that is going
on within the cerebellum
that is what is the
nature of coordination
taking all the inputs
which are basically
multiplied and
decorrelated in the granule
cell layer from all those
sources of information
that we have from
the mossy fibers and
then the output of
the cerebellum is a
reduction of all these
inputs that's good kind
of sky high view of
what it means to have
coordination taking all
this information and
compressing it down just
like how a regression
line would be able
to summarize a bunch
of points of data and
now you just say y
equals a x plus b as
opposed to you know 20
000 data points that's
kind of a sky high view
of what's going on so
let's summarize the
internal connections
that you do need to
be um competent in
and understand that is
that there are climbing
fibers and mossy fibers
climbing fibers originate
from the inferior
olive they excite
cerebellar cortex and
the deep cerebellar
nuclei the mossy fibers
are all the other
afferents that enter into
the cerebellum they'll
also excite the
cerebellar cortex and
deep cerebellar nuclei
the purkenji cells are
the output of the cortex
not necessarily that
not necessarily the
output of the cerebellum
but for the most
they are the output of
the cerebellar cortex.
Most of the output
from the cerebellum is
through the deep
cerebellar nuclei. They're
going to be processing
the inputs from
those three sources listed
above as the difference
between the two.
The one exception is
the simplest functional
division of the
vestibulocerebellum and
its output is going to
be from cerebellar
cortex it does not have
to go vis-a-vis a deep
cerebellar nucleus.
Cerebellar
disorders can result
from causes as diverse as
exposure to
lithium, chickenpox,
or multiple
sclerosis. There There
are so many different
disorders and
traumas and events
that can impact
the cerebellum given
its size and its
placement and its
vascular supply.
Ataxia is the most
common symptom of
all of these and ataxia
again is the lack
of order, ataxia.
So you'd have a
discoordination in the
timing and magnitude
of movement. This
could lead to
overshoots and
misdirected movements and
at the end, as a
compensatory process,
oscillations about
the endpoint.
It is not expressed as
weakness. There's no
paralysis that is
involved or spasticity.
So it is quite
different than the upper
motor neuron disorders
that we characterized
before and the lower
motor neurons we
characterized before.
This is extrapyramidal. So
the symptoms are broadly
similar to what we
see with alcohol
intoxication, at least
insofar as their motor
expression. And this
is what we scrutinized
in a, quote, standard
field sobriety test.
can the person walk
on a straight line
what do the eyes look
like when they're trying
to follow a pen can
they touch their finger
to their nose and
so a few other important
points as that damage
to just one region
mean functional region
of the cerebellum
is rare because for
example each cerebellar
artery will supply
multiple divisions
and then events like
hydrocephalus that would
act to push the tonsils
down would affect
both the spinal
cerebellum and the
vestibulocerebellum
but the the the the
symptoms that one
shows is still
nonetheless reflecting
dysfunction of
particular specialized
regions and we can
most certainly say that
damage specifically
to one side would
impact coordination on
the same side because
cerebellum controls
the ipsilateral body.
Signatures of damage to
the cerebrocerebellum
or that would be
pontocerebellar disorders
or damage to the
lateral hemispheres.
There's a number of
ways of describing that
because they all go
together. The symptoms
would include ataxia as
we discussed before but
more specifically
this intention tremor.
I mentioned the
oscillations that are very
evident at the intended
terminus of the movement
and this is not a
resting tremor there
is this great word
uh dysdiadachokinesia
okay so dysdiadachokinesia
ddk this would be
the person's trying to
quickly supinate their
hand pronate their hand
and they just don't
do it an orderly way
you could do with
supination you could
also do it with the foot
and and tapping there's
slurred speech so
it's not just the
cerebellum is involved in
controlling their
limbs it's involved in
controlling speech
speech is a very precise
well-timed behavior
so and if somebody has
drank to excess you
can see that they throw
their speech this is
because they are deficient
in the engagement of
cerebellar mechanisms
to coordinate that
movement there's also
low muscle tone. Now
some of the causes for
this would be to affect
nucleic nuclei or
lateral hemisphere or
pontine degeneration.
Spinal cerebellar
dysfunction would be manifest
in a toxic gait. That
is the signature.
A toxic gait is a
person who tries to walk
forward and they're
going to be stumbling
they're going to be
stepping in a regular way
they'll have a wide
stance if you ask them to
have a lombard stance
of going heel toe heel
toe then you really
can see that they they
easily fall over
this is as if they're
intoxicated by alcohol
so you could have this
result from chronic
alcohol ***** you could
have this result from
an underdeveloped vermis
that's occurs with
Dandy-Walker syndrome.
You could have this if
the tonsils are displaced
with Arnold-Chiari
syndrome. So anything
that'd be affecting
that vermis and the
paravermis or the region
immediately around that,
the medial hemispheres,
then would lead
to spinal cerebellar
expressions of dysfunction
last that we have
dysfunction of the
vestibulocerebellum so
this is the floccular
nodule lobe and this would
be involved in orienting
one's body being able
to tell what's up
what's down and
controlling various aspects
of eye movement so
the symptoms would be
wide stance because they
don't know what's up
what's down they feel
unsteady on their feet
they feel dizzy so
they're going to spread
their legs out if they
do fall they you know
they might reliably
fall on one side because
we have that ipsilateral
control of the
vestibulospinal system
that activates those anti
-gravity muscles of
the leg to extend the
lead it if instead you
supported the body if
you you know brace
them and put them on a
seat they could move their
limbs in a coordinated
way but that wouldn't
work in the real
world because they
wouldn't know if they're
have like leaning to
one side or leaning to
the other as a cat these
persistent oscillatory
saccades that are
called nystagmus so your
eyes just moving like
it's uh they'll have
a uh like a beat they'll
call it beating to
the side but but but
looking to the side
looking back looking
aside it's like an
oscillation then that
is a characteristic of
vestibulocerebellar
dysfunction that's something
that's tested you know
in a roadside battery
if a police officer
thought that you're
inebriated uh vertigo
and nausea is referring
to vertigo but you also
feel the symptoms of
oh, I feel awful because
I feel like I'm spinning.
And so some causes
for this would be
medulloblastoma, which
as you might know is a
common childhood
cancer, the most common
childhood cancer. It
actually originates within
the cerebellum. There's
viral infections.
I mentioned chicken
pox before. So you can
have an acute case of
vestibulocerebellar
dysfunction and just
it'll just go away you
know chicken pox goes
away so some of these
are problems that
really are going to
reflect deeply serious
and long-lasting and
sometimes you know
we wish it was more
often that they could
just go away and resolve
by their own themselves
a handy dandy
mnemonic that will
help you to look for
cerebellar symptoms
and you now should know
what each of the
components of this
mnemonic is Danish so
that's dys, dyadacko,
kinesia,
ataxia,
nystagmus,
tension tremor,
speech,
hypotonia,
Danish.
Essential tremor is
the most common motor
disorder affects two
percent of the population
just imagine how many
people that you know
that separate you might
as well it might be
small now and to become
more and more prominent
later on not
everybody's going to be
going to a movement
specialist there are some
things that can get by
depending on how severe
it is nonetheless it
is a disorder and it
is the most common
disorder so it's a tremor
this oscillations the
primarily seen in the
upper limb 95% of cases
involved the upper
limb it is present if
somebody holds their
harm out steadily or
if they're reaching to
a target but it's not
seen if a person's
relaxed that complete
puts their hand in the lap
but have with rest tremor
seen in parkinson's
disease and it's
not intention tremor
seen with uh you know
characteristic uh of of
cerebellar damage
where you have this uh
don't have it during
postural hold and you see
it grow and grow and
grow during a reach as
one approaches a target
instead you see it
during posture and you
see it during movement
but about equal
amplitude can also affect
the vocal cord so as
someone speaking they
have a shaky voice chances
are that's a central
tremor not associated
with Parkinson's
disease becomes apparent
around mid midlife
it's progressive has a
strong genetic component
50% inheritance for
those individuals that
have been identified
for ET, they'll have a
kid with ET. Last
thing is that it is not
known for sure what is
the cause, but the best
bet, the consensus
view, is cerebellum,
which is interesting
because it's not ataxia,
it's not
discoordination in that
way, and it's not
intention tremor.
But it seems to involve
basal cerebellum,
but, you know,
there's a lot of
dysfunctions that
you get from, you
know, such a large,
complex circuit.
So anyway, that is
essential treatment.
All right, we've
reached the end.
Let us summarize.
The cerebellum
is composed of a
cortical sheet of
internal nuclei.
It processes information
from the spinal
cord, brainstem, and
cerebral cortex. The
functional divisions
are defined by cortical
territory, output
nuclei, and capabilities.
Its information
processing involves mossy
fibers, climbing
fibers, granule cells,
burgundy cells, and
deep cerebellar nuclei.
The cerebellum is
essential for coordination,
and dysfunction is
manifest as ataxia.
As always, I hope that
was a clear presentation
of what our undoubtedly
some complex
facts and concepts.
Feedback is appreciated.